spongeBob is crossing over into the real
world place that could be great or
terrible I explained why on this week's
episode of angry dirt the second
spongebob movie sets computer-generated
versions of the cartoon sea creatures
loose among real people there's a rich
history Daffy and Donald Duck did it so
did Jerry the mouse and then there is
the masterpiece Who Framed Roger Rabbit
now mixing cartoon characters with
real-life settings is deceptively tricky
to pull off human actors have to react
to characters and haven't been added in
yet how do they know where to look
animators also have to make the
characters fit into the world around it
takes a lot of talent
and a lot of money to pull that off what
just ask my new sidekick Gary the
wisecracking honey badger sub Gary
high-five ya see how Gary casts a
realistic shadow here that takes
thousands of man-hours to pull off so we
definitely have the budget to add in a
CG character right several look really
stupid if we don't promise okay hey Gary
stop break down so you can pay attention
to my red yeah purple furred rascal
anyway toons in the real world films can
go terribly wrong like in the 1977
Disney flick Pete's dragon oh who did
the compositing on this what's that Gary
oak ooh burn you said it Gary not me now
you think this sort of crossover would
get easier in the era of sophisticated
computer animation but the track record
is terrible I can't think of a single
computer-generated cartoon crossover
that's half as good a Space Jam I mean
you have the early attempts like Casper
what the CG tech was new how did they
manage to make an ethereal translucent
blob look phony you had the Adventures
of Rocky and Bullwinkle and the charm of
the original cartoons was
were so rough and sketchy the 3d CG
versions totally lost his charm the
characters look less appealing than the
Parade Float versions links scooby-doo
sucks robbery the design of this iconic
character just feels off from facial
structure to fur texture Matt Lillard
does a better job of becoming a cartoon
character than the animators do with
making Scoob seem tangible the Chipmunks
Yogi Bear Garfield I hated these but
that was because they were poorly
written and simple not because his CG
was particularly terrible what worries
me now is that war movies will do what
the new Ninja Turtles did try to make
comic book characters look as detailed
and realistic as gone oh look at those
faces it's like they hit the bottom of
the uncanny valley and started digging
so how will the new spongebob fare well
the character design is fun not too
phony not creepily realistic I like that
they're in the real world but they can
still do cartoony physics-defying tricks
good writing helps a lot and the
spongebob series definitely has that I
guess I'm cautiously optimistic what do
you think let me know in the comments
and let me know if you buy merchandise
featuring my animated sidekick Gary what
no you don't earn a percentage of sales
Gary you know you really need to read
contracts before you sign up hey the
spongebob movie has got to be better
than The Smurfs in that right Gary
testify whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa don't
use that kind of language on my show
Gary well it's true what they say you
just don't care do you
Disney is actually prepping a remake of
Pete's dragon what do you think do you
want to see that let me know in the
comments
oh and click on these other wired videos
over here for more of my rants